gop senators releasing shocking new
images from our southern border
senator ted cruz saying quote these are
the pictures the biden administration
doesn't want the american people
to see they show cramped and overcrowded
conditions at a child migrant facility
in donna texas the group of 17
senators demanding president biden take
action to solve the problem
the images they're releasing are in
stark contrast to what the white house
allowed a single media camera to see
this week the video on the right is of
an hhs facility that is not
overcrowded child migrants get there
days after they are processed by border
patrol
and while we're seeing the reality on
the ground president biden making some
big claims about the border that aren't
entirely lining up with the facts
i guess i should be flattered people are
coming because i'm the nice guy
28 percent increase in children to the
border in my administration
31 in the last year of
in 2019 before the pandemic in the trump
administration
it happens every single solitary year
the vast majority the overwhelming
majority of people
coming to the border crossing are being
sent back
so he says a winter surge is happening
every year but the numbers show major
increases under his administration of
both
migrant and child migrant encounters
so katie want to bring you in here um
lindsey graham said earlier graham very
upset as many of them were speaking
there and he said he was told by a top
border official
that they briefed the biden transition
team they were asked what happens if we
roll back these specific trump
policies he says that they were told
this is exactly what's going to happen
so he says now i want to find out who
was briefed who within the bind
administration knew about this and
decided to move forward
your impression of what we've heard from
the senators this afternoon
well not just what we've heard but what
we're seeing with our own eyes shannon
it's one thing to listen to politicians
from
either side of the aisle talk about this
issue but when you can see what's
happening
and something that the white house has
refused to release to the public
you can see that they've been lying to
the american people they've been trying
to say that they're open to transparency
that they should be praised for letting
one
pool camera into an hhs facility which
is not what we're seeing on the screen
right now this is a cbp facility where
they're overwhelmingly uh they're
overwhelmed there's
there are too many people they're at a
thousand percent capacity in a lot of
places the coveted rate in these places
is ten
percent and there's a quote from jen
stockey on february 23
where she said to kristen fisher i'm
sure you're not uh suggesting that we
have children right next to each other
in ways
that are not covered safe are you when
we were asking about this
this surge and here you are on your
screen looking at people
sitting laying side by side overcrowded
and it's just an interesting question
for the white house press team because
in the age of information this was
inevitably going to happen when you have
senators
republicans going to the border who have
connections inside of cbp who have been
set up to fail by the administration by
the way
we're going to eventually see these
photos and yet the white house has been
lying to us
about the situation and at some point
americans have
their own eyes and ears and they can see
exactly what's going on and the
messaging becomes
insulting and they can clearly see that
the white house has not been
honest with them about what is actually
happening especially after biden's press
conference yesterday
and juan these images i want to get your
impression because
president trump was ripped for things
that weren't even this bad i mean he was
raked across the coals constantly
we also have president biden yesterday
saying things that are demonstrably
false talking about the vast majority of
people being sent back
when the numbers coming from federal
government agencies
don't line up with that i mean that's
not fox news collecting the news i mean
these are coming from official agencies
one how do you respond to these images
well first on the images you know i
think they're cramped
just like katie was saying but to my
mind what you're seeing there's a lot of
thermal blankets uh you know i think
that's fine but
what we know even before the images is
we were experiencing a surge at the
border and
we're trying to be more humane in
keeping with american values when it
comes to
helping these young people not setting
them back out
you know on some dangerous
life-threatening trek in the desert so
what i understand is you know i it i
don't think it looks inhumane it
certainly looks cramped
and with regard to covet i think what
we've been told and i don't
i can't vouch for it but i can say this
is what we've been told is that
the young people who test positive for
covet about 10
are quarantined so they wouldn't be in
this group nonetheless it's distressing
you hope that they can fix this
on the numbers i think i don't know what
numbers you're referring to because i
think everybody agrees that
most of the adults are being turned back
it's overwhelming
um and then the second thing to say and
i think this is really important
i may sound like a broken record i
apologize but i just think we've got to
get together as an american people and
say hey you want congress do your job
you know we came together in 2013 i
think there were 15 republicans voting
with
the democrats it didn't happen it's
broken down now
but we need that's the busiest border in
the world high commerce
our busiest border we need to fix it fix
border security
fix the dreamers fix the kids fix for
people who are here
let's get to work congress okay listen
greg
that's been the that's been the argument
whether democrats have controlled
everything whether republicans have
controlled everything it has not gotten
done
and if you want to talk about inhumane
you heard these senators and we've heard
many other people
including democratic congressmen say
what they're seeing that these kids and
these families are going through on the
way
getting here is anything but humane
absolutely uh and uh
but i think we're overblowing this is
overblown those are thermal blankets
so everything's cool we got the thermal
blankets those aren't thermal blankets
those are biden's baked potatoes
that's what they are he should be he
should be shamed for this
because as you said shannon he incited
them to come over here
trump made it a 45-year low by using
disincentives
especially with mexico right so joe
removed the disincentives
and replaced them with appeasement
signals and this is what you get he
turned a no way
into a hop on board joe's like that guy
that are your worst friend in school who
ever
who tells everybody that you're throwing
a party and then by eight o'clock your
house is destroyed
and the cops have shut it down and
that's what that what joe has done is he
invited these
invited these caravans over and then
pretends like oh
it's the weather it's the weather the
only weather that caused us was joe's
hot air
and the whole idea that it's happened
before we already destroyed that
argument it happened before because of
the sanctuary cities
and the vocal democrats that were
enticing people over here
uh with with again very
obvious incentivized appeasement signals
lastly i kind of like the fact that in
order to get the media to cover a story
you got to send like
half the senate and short sleeve gap
shirts and night vision goggles
you know we should probably be doing
this with other stories like
how do we deal with the homeless in the
in in all of our downtown cities
how are we dealing with the crime in our
downtown cities maybe we should be
sending senators there
and then maybe the media might cover
that outrageous stuff
yeah jesse they're in their sporty spice
outfits but it is getting a lot of
attention i want to mention one thing
the president said yesterday this was a
winter surge
but i think we might have some numbers
here because what we've been told before
this is it's a spring surge
every year and actually the numbers for
this february versus last are way up i
think there may be two to three times as
many
what do you make of what we're seeing
jesse
well they say illegal immigrants do the
jobs that americans won't do
now politicians are doing the jobs that
the media won't do
the media should be taking these
pictures
not senator ted cruz or senator langford
joe biden in the media have this twisted
arrangement where
joe biden takes away their first
amendment takes away the freedom of the
press
and then the media pretends to care the
media says oh joe
will you please let us do our job and
cover what you're doing at the border
and joe says no we have to cover it up a
little bit more
and they say when and joe says i don't
know i'll let you know and they say okay
they pat themselves on the back and they
go back to attacking republicans
these pictures are sad they're
preventable it's not the us's role
to accept every single teenager in the
western hemisphere
that sets foot on our soil or every
adult who grabs a teen in mexico
and sets foot on our soul juan says this
is compassionate
this is cruelty joe biden is aiding and
abetting
human slavery done by the drug cartels
every single picture of that person that
you see
has paid a coyote and if they don't have
the cash up front they have to work
off the debt here in the united states
they do that through drugs
prostitution or slave labor
and when they work off the debt they go
work off
more debt for u.s companies wealthy
individuals who run hotels
and have estates that again is another
form of indentured servitude
joe biden should be ashamed of himself
he supports this type of behavior
and for wan to say that he's okay with
these images
as a father as an american citizen
i don't think that's compassionate juan
i'm disturbed with what i said i do
and you should be too listen the
pictures are a
a pr nightmare for this administration
especially after that presser yesterday
but let us not forget the first images
we got out of this situation for a
were from a democratic congressman this
is a bipartisan issue
and maybe they can get to work on it